ou pas mettre à l'ère la professeure
titulaire faculté de rennes versement
réel m roy bonsoir bonsoir monsieur roy
alors je pense vous êtes la personne à
qui il faut parler parce que les droits
des animaux vous connaissez ça est ce
que m gaulois de ou d'autres personnes
ou des groupes de défense pour les
droits des animaux avait une poignée
juridique une poignée légales pour faire
arrêter cet abattage
en fait il ya toujours la poignée du
droit administratif qui compte
pourquoi véritablement le droit
animalier à savoir s'ils avaient de
longueuil avait le pouvoir d'adopter
cette résolution avait le pouvoir de
prendre une décision comme celle là si
la réglementation ou la loi le lui
permettait à savoir que les animaux
élevés effectivement de sa compétence
des éléments donc de droit administratif
qu'un administratives y serait beaucoup
mieux placé que moi pour discuter nos
adversaires il ya depuis 2015 dans le
code civil
un article fondamental qu'on oublie
encore malheureusement l'artiste des 880
18.1 qui a instant par une nouvelle
définition de l'animal depuis 2015
l'animal n'est plus définie comme une
chose comme un bien meuble comme c'était
le cas autrefois
l'animal est maintenant définie comme un
être sensible qui a des impératifs
biologiques c'est à dire des besoins
essentiels d'ordre physiologique d'ordre
refusé d'entendre comportementale qu'on
évalue en fonction de la taille de
l'espèce des capacités cognitives et
d'autres facteurs
alors cette mission là elle est
extrêmement porteur en terme de droit
animalier elle laisse entrevoir des
développements probants quand je regarde
la proposition initiale de la ville de
longueuil
ben je constate que le plan n'était
absolument pas conforme à la nature même
de l'animal ne faisait pas écho à cette
définition de l'animal on y voyait
plutôt l'animal en termes de choses ou
en termes de ressources
gasquet est
changement de définition qu'on a apporté
au québec donc passant d'une chose d'un
bien meuble à un être avec une
sensibilité
est-ce que ça s'arrête plus est ce que
ça a donné des droits supplémentaires à
ses chèvres il a ou pas je pense qu'on
aurait pu effectivement amener un
tribunal à se baser sur cette définition
pour concevoir le plan de la ville de
longueuil qui entrevoyait la nuit pas
comme une simple ressource dans un
système dans un écosystème bon parfois
il ya des espèces végétales qui sont
visibles il ya un frêne qui est atteint
d'un grill alors on élabore ben c'est un
peu comme ça que le plan d'orgueil
appréhendait les serres ces trois
ressources nuisible pour l'écosystème
alors on les avait pourtant quand je
conçois l'animal en terme d'être
sensible que des impératifs biologiques
je reconnais davantage d'harmonie de la
proposition de l'organisme sur le tas
l'animalerie qiu shi proposer une
alternative respectueuse à mon sens de
cette nouvelle définition des mâles
d'accord mais m roy ou en thrace la lune
patio découvre qu'il y a par exemple
trop de rameau rien est ce que on va
voir des gens dire on ne peut pas
abattre ou tuer se débarrasser de rats
parce que ils ont maintenant on les
considère autre chose que des jo où
justement il restera toujours selon le
critère de la nécessité absolue
la nécessité disons que font les
interpréter de façon très très large
avec les années bon dans les codes et sa
mère il ya km et internet hirsch et des
avis qui démontrait que on pouvait aller
au delà battage que ce n'était pas
nécessaire qu'il y avait possibilité de
sauver ses serres et de toute façon on
le voit bien la ville de longueuil a
décidé d'adhérer à marquer on verra si
vous
on verra s'ils vont survivre qu'on va
les déplacés parce que des biologistes
disait qu'on ne peut pas les déplacer
mais on verra en donnant une chose à la
libye mais que bien sûr m roy c est ce
que notre notre droit est différent en
fonction de la beauté de l'animal
quand c'est un cerf ou ans que nous on
appelle ici au québec un chevreuil c'est
très beau alors on est ému mais quand
c'est des animaux propos quand c'est des
animaux qu'on va manger des pommes et là
c'est pas grave on peut les abattre ces
deux poids deux mesures absolument
d'accord avec vous ça rien à voir avec
la beauté l'animal ou même avec notre
animateur de considérations morales
était qu'animal c'est la capacité de
ressentir c'est le caractère sensible de
notre animal alors est ce que c'est un
animal ce type de souffrir de vivent de
la détresse de ville de la souffrance à
le critère de considérations morales en
éthique animal est dès lors que vous
fassiez souffrir un chien ou que vous
fassiez souffrir un parent c'est tout
aussi à catane donc absolument rien à
voir avec la beauté ou le rapport qu'on
entretient avec ses animaux la bienvenue
dans l'edition mal on met le mouvement
social le mouvement sur les réseaux
sociaux et est plus facile lorsqu'il
s'agit d'animaux que l'on juge joli
minoi comme des petits toutous la wii de
fer ayant une certaine une certaine
hypocrisie sociale faut pas se le cacher
alors on s'émeut de 15 de serre mais bon
si on consomme des serres de viande de
gibier il ya des choses profondément et
cohérent une science cognitive
c'est la même chose avec le phénomène du
cochon qui tombe d'un camion de 30 ans
vers l'abattage
alors tout le monde est très ému par ce
cochon et ont vu le confirme refuge on
peut le soigner
mais bon on se fout un peu des 150
autres cochons qui sont dans le camion
qui s'en vont directement à l'abattoir
regardez les dindes de l'action grâce
aux états unis qui sont versés par le
plus tard c'est quelque chose de plus
ridicule que sort
sur le politique à l'image pense qu'on
doit répondre de façon affirmative
je vais vous réinviter très bientôt
mettre roi pour parler de l'éléphant api
convention au vélodrome ce qui est
esseulé
on l'a laissé seul pendant 10 ans puis
c'est en cour suprême de l'état de new
york cette histoire-là exact est-ce
qu'il a des droits ou non un second
panel sauver m roy merci à très bientôt
merci à vous au revoir